[الموسيقى]
غالبًا ما يستخدم الزنجبيل لتزيين طبق
أو إضافة التوابل إلى الوجبة ، لكن مجموعة
متزايدة من الأبحاث تظهر أن هذا الطريق
يمكن أن يكون له فوائد كبيرة لدراسات الصحة العامة
التي تشير إلى أن الزنجبيل يمكن أن يساعد في
اضطرابات المعدة الشائعة التي غالبًا ما تسببها
الغثيان المرتبط  الحمل أو
العلاج الكيميائي إحدى الطرق السهلة لإدخال الزنجبيل
في نظامك الغذائي تتمثل في
مزيج عصير الفطور ، مزيج 1 جزرة 3 تفاح وقطعة 1
بوصة من جذر الزنجبيل مع عصير
الليمون ثم تقليب واحتساء
طريقة أخرى سهلة لإضافة الزنجبيل إلى نظامك
الغذائي  اهرسها في
حساء اليقطين بالزنجبيل أو أضفه إلى وجبتك المفضلة
كصلصة ، يمكن أن يساعدك الزنجبيل الإضافي الآخر
على الاسترخاء بعد الذهاب إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية
وفقًا لدراسة أجرتها جامعة جورجيا
عند تناول الزنجبيل إما نيئًا
أو ساخنًا ، فهو يساعد في تخفيف آلام العضلات
بعد ذلك.  يساعد التمرين بنسبة تصل إلى 25٪ من
الزنجبيل على تحسين الدورة
الدموية وإرخاء العضلات المحيطة بالأوعية
الدموية ، ويمكن أن يكون له نفس
تأثير تخفيف الآلام للنساء اللاتي يعانين من
تقلصات الدورة الشهرية.